I think like the biggest issue with
Facebook was that it tried to be an
everything app and it just became really
hard to navigate just want to go on
there and speak to my friends and
comment and post but then I started
seeing like apartments and shopping and
then like the marketplace and now I
think there's like a dating Tinder thing
on there and it's just became impossible
to operate and I'm just worried that
that same mentality will be the same
thing for Twitter because he's trying to
make Twitter and all in one app
rebranding your ex he wants to make it a
place for shopping for finances and all
of that that one app a bit like China's
WeChat that's what he wants to do